You know, a lot of people I interview have had fleeting interactions in one-off instances.
You know, they've been abducted by a gray or they've, you know, interacted with a tall white or a Nordic.
You've had years of interactions with all three, but mostly with the tall whites.
There was this giant white radioactive horse that floated around the ranges at night and was fluorescent.
The extraterrestrials, when they come, even if they're your good friends, there's always a tension because they always come heavily armed.
Today's amazing guest on American Alchemy has seen the inside of a UFO.
He's a firsthand witness to the collaboration between human beings and aliens from another world.
He's even made an alien laugh.
Charles Hall was in the Air Force.
He was also stationed.
And at the notorious Area 51.
While stationed there, he was in regular contact with an alien race that he calls the tall whites for two years.
This conversation is absolutely wild.
There's a guy at NASA who has a deep interest in these sorts of things, experiencers.
His name is Timothy Taylor.
Have you heard of him by any chance?
Did you say Timothy Taylor?
Yeah.
He's a good friend of ours.
We're going to be talking about aliens going to the bathroom.
What powers?
A UFO and theories of subatomic physics that overturn Einstein.
Before we get into it, I want to introduce our guest, Charles Hall.
Hall enlisted in the US Air Force in 1964 when he was just 19 years old.
He trained as a weather observer, measuring wind speeds, cloud cover and visibility from 1965 to 1967.
He was stationed at Nellis Air Force Base in Nevada.
His job included long, isolated tours at the Indian Springs.
He was also a pilot for the American Air Force.
He was a member of the Indian Air Force's Unit 13 Plane number 152, which is the desk
that many Earth crew trained in preparing for nuclearestänt combat.
He was aiming into NASA's I propaganda foothold and his magic doll will help us out.
This is Charles Hall, and he has some funny adventaginess.
Our guest is one of the best porta-patrikers in NASA.
He was a sport member with his background in both biomechanics and Franklin Jacobs.
Why조
It's a very peculiar method of identification and video.
물 y
The
brief
language
in the
and given a medical discharge others flat out refused to return to the post but hall was very
different something about who he was meant that he wasn't going to break like the others had and
both his commanders and these tall white beings seemed to take notice in this isolated crucible
he began slowly interacting with the tall whites these beings would stalk him and test him appear
suddenly and vanish slowly gauging his reactions but he eventually learned this unwritten language
and although there were some painful setbacks he gradually developed a trust he saw family
groups parents children elders he would even end up referring to one of them as something
like a brother hall claims that the tall whites lived in underground facilities at the north end
of indian springs valley complete with hangers for their craft a story bearing
striking resemblance to that of bob lazar he learned about their different flying crafts
and as you'll see in our conversation what he saw comports with much of what we've learned about uaps
since 2017. but the tall whites were not the only alien race described in this story
hall has talked about the greys the small frail large-headed humanoids that match the classic
roswell image the tall white technology was better than the technology of the greys
but the greys come from a planet that's closer than the planet the tall whites come from and
the greys got here first and then there are the nordics what you'll hear hall refer to
as the norwegians with the 24 teeth hall described them as more patient more diplomatic even
benevolent compared to the tall whites some of them could pass among humans in the public
sometimes blending into crowds there is no end to the speculation about how these
species might interact with humanity's evolution or social development if all of this sounds crazy
well yeah i don't blame you and trust me we've only scratched the surface here i personally don't
even know what to make about this conversation there are things charles hall is about to say
that feel beyond the pale to me so that's my primer for you without further ado please
welcome this week's amazing american alchemist charles hall
today's episode is sponsored by incogni before we dive into today's episode of american alchemy i
want to give a quick shout out to our amazing sponsor incogni this is a service that i use to
make all of my personal information vanish from the sketchiest corners of the internet
here's a fun but slightly terrifying experiment google your full name plus your city what comes
up old addresses family members court records you didn't even know were public and maybe some bizarre
risk profile that makes you sound like a bond villain that's all thanks to data brokers
companies you've never heard of quietly buying selling and reselling your personal information
to advertisers political campaigns insurers even scammers incogni fights them for you they contact
over 250 data brokers they demand your data to be deleted and follow up until it's actually gone
and now they've launched something called custom removals
part of their unlimited plan here's the upgrade if you find your information on any site anywhere
on the internet even ones outside of their automated system you just paste the link into
your dashboard and incogni's privacy team will personally get it taken down and you get unlimited
requests think sites like whitepages.com trellis.law or unicort.com places you'd never visit
but where your data somehow lives rent free i personally use it because i don't have the
time or quite frankly the patience to chase down every obscure website that's selling my address
for two dollars and fifty cents and with incogni i don't have to so take your personal data back with
incogni use code americanalchemy or go to incogni.com americanalchemy to get 60 off an annual
plan again that is 60 off an annual plan that's over half the normal price off online privacy
isn't about paranoia it's about control it's about control it's about control it's about control
and this is one of the easiest ways to get some of that control back so don't put it off take care of
your internet hygiene now let's get back into this crazy episode i'm here with charles hall um it's an
honor to have you it's been a long time coming you're the subject of an amazing documentary by
uh emil marzak called walking with the tall whites uh but you've also uh written a series of amazing
books called millennial hospitality you have six volumes there's six points you have six volumes at
all and uh you've interacted with you know a lot of people i interview have had fleeting interactions
in one-off instances you know they've been abducted by a gray or they've you know interacted
with a a tall white or a nordic you've had years of interactions uh with all three but
mostly with the tall whites and i really want to uh dive into that but first i want to talk
about your hall photon theory uh you believe that einstein is wrong
i'm quite certain einstein was wrong the and i've also written books entitled beyond relativity and
i've done a rumble video entitled mirage galaxies and edges in space edges is spelled with capital
letters because it's a zone and i've also done a second um i've done a second um
um video called mirage galaxies and edges in space
uh film with emil marzak which discusses that called walking with the tall whites aftermath
and i've also caught that's all copyrighted hall photon theory
i first copyrighted hall photon theory in 1997 and i'm quite certain that there are
many more particles subatomic particles and many more types of force fields
avail
that in the in the na Seni
for
the audience uh you are extremely smart you have a master's degree in nuclear physics and you scored off the
on the Air Force Mathability Test.
It was the one I was marking as I was marking
the correct answer as the clock had sounded
and they were ripping the answer sheet from my cold hands.
If they'd just given me 10 more seconds,
I'd have got them all.
That's amazing, but you told me off air
that what inspired this Hall photon theory
was you actually seeing a craft
and realizing it could go faster than light.
So you were stationed at Area 51.
That's correct.
I was a weather observer in the U.S. Air Force
and I was stationed at Nellis Air Force Base
from March of 1965 until May of 1967.
And Nellis is in charge of the gunnery ranges
at Indian Springs.
And I was a duty weather observer at Indian Springs.
Area 51 in 1965 was just the entry area
to the areas.
And the areas went up to number 60
and I've been in all of them.
The areas were assembled into lands.
One, the most famous land was Dreamland.
Area 51 was not actually Dreamland itself.
It was merely Groom Lake.
Dreamland was Area 53 and 54,
which was the northern half of Indian Springs Valley.
And then the valley to the east, Dogbone Valley,
and part of the valley to the west, including French Peak.
The biggest shock was not that extraterrestrials
were here on Earth and had been ever since
at least the Ice Age.
The biggest shock that I felt was discovering
that Einstein was wrong about relativity.
The craft that the tall whites and the grays came in,
the Roswell grays came in,
could easily exceed the speed of light by many times.
The tall white technology was better
than the technology of the grays.
But the grays come from a planet that's closer
than the planet the tall whites come from.
And the grays got here first.
So I would guess that 90% of the time
that you see an actual extraterrestrial
craft, it's one of the gray craft.
And about 10% of the time, it's one of the tall white craft.
And the grays are much more numerous for that reason.
I remember the shock when I really, truly understood
that Einstein was wrong about relativity.
I was out at range three as the duty weather observer.
What year is this?
And this was in the mid-1960s.
This was like in 1915.
This was in 1965, the late summer.
And there was a six-week or two-month period
where I was certain that the tall white individuals
who identified themselves as the teacher
and range four Harry and tour guide,
who were my good friends,
that they had taken a vacation or a business trip somewhere
and that they weren't on this planet, and that they
had gone to some other inhabited planet orbiting
some other star.
A reasonable guess would have been the star Arcturus
or a star near Arcturus.
Then they came back.
I believe they'd been on a business trip
slash vacation-type trip.
Now, Arcturus is 36 light years away.
And the nearest star, Alpha Centauri,
is almost four light years away.
It's a group of three stars.
And to go anywhere and come back to another star,
the craft you're on had to travel quite a few times faster
than the speed of light, like 44 times or something minimum,
just to go there and come back in two months.
I think a lot of people in the audience might hear
that they're coming back and forth from, you know,
a star system that is 36 light years away
and want to know some core details
as to what you are seeing.
Do you see crafts coming in?
And what do the crafts look like on schedule?
On schedule on the night of the Full Moon
or a few days before or a few days after,
but their base at the north end of Indian Springs,
they were using Dog Bone Lake
as their landing field.
What do they do crafts look like?
Like Tic Tacs.
Yeah, like eggs, like white eggs that were egg-shaped.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Oh. I see. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
Were they of the kind of, you know, David Fravor, 2004, the Nimitz sighting, where you have a tic-tac, or was it like the egg that Jake Barber or, you know, Socorro, New Mexico, 64, you know, those are two different, or both shapes?
When I first saw them, it reminded me the most of like a large version of the engine of a passenger train, only with everything rounded like an egg. There are no sharp edges, no sharp protrusions, just smooth and round like a round, it was ellipsoidal, okay?
Any hieroglyphics or symbols?
Not in the outside.
When you went on, their writing is hieroglyphics, more so. Their writing, if you didn't know Egyptian hieroglyphics, some, a couple of the guys that were with me who had seen them thought that they were ancient Egyptians who had somehow or another gotten into the Indian Springs Valley and trapped there, and were still using their own hieroglyphics.
Who thought that?
A couple of the other range men, yeah.
Interesting.
And they can stand right there.
I'm standing right in front of you.
I speak from direct experience.
And if they feel like talking to each other using sounds too high for a human to hear, they'll do so.
And if you didn't know better, you'd think they were able to do telepathy, because they'll be sitting there in total silence and want to laugh, and then they'll be going through a complete conversation.
And of course, their electronics also are able to tell what a person is thinking.
And to put thoughts in the conscious part of their mind by electronic means.
Why do you think that?
From direct experience.
Did they have a device that could implant thoughts?
Yeah, only it wasn't a big device that they had to carry in their hands.
It was one that they'd carry like on a helmet or whatever, you know?
And what's the broader context here?
Are you sort of this rogue Air Force range men?
Or do the other range men and superiors, are they aware of this ET presence coexisting alongside you guys at this testing complex?
And is it sort of a, there's just this kind of awareness that there's this cohabitation there?
The Pentagon had a tiny handful of people that knew, that interacted with them.
The range maintenance men...
A few knew they were there, but most of them just knew about the legend of Range 4 Harry.
The range, the legend of Range 4 Harry was that there was this giant white radioactive horse
that floated around the ranges at night and was fluorescent.
And supposedly it was a horse that had gotten too close to the bomb blasts at Yucca Platts.
And you'd see him on warm summer nights from a distance, and you could stay, but you needed to stay away from him.
And he was called Range 4 Harry.
Now there was an actual tall white guy with the name Range 4 Harry.
And the tall whites, when they were wearing their protective suits, could form up into a high-speed horse formation.
Like if there were a typical one, as if there were...
If there were two women, a couple, three kids, children, and two men,
the two women would be in front and bend over and at the waist and bend forward and put their arms out like that, some usually,
and they would be the front of the horse.
And then the three children would, who remember their suits, the technology of them, allowed them to float.
Nine or ten inches off the ground.
They could float a lot higher if they wanted to, but they had to balance themselves.
And the children would float, whose suits were a slightly different design, would float higher so that they were floating at about the waist level.
So you'd have the two women in front and the three children.
Then at the back, you'd have the two men, who had bigger suits and more powerful packs, and they would bend over, over the children.
So if they were in front of the horse, they would be in front of the children.
And if you saw them when they were out in the desert, say a quarter mile away, when they all turned on their suits,
the force fields from around those suits merged into one.
And I speak from direct experience.
You would swear there was a giant white floating horse coming at you from out in the desert.
Now, that horse could, when they were in that formation, the reason I call it the high-speed horse formation,
is because when they, I personally watched them, when they wanted to go somewhere, when they were out hiking,
say like, and they wanted to go somewhere fast, they could form up into that formation,
and they could reach speeds of 100 miles an hour over the desert by floating up above the ground and just going zoom.
I used to watch them play at the runways at Indian Springs Air Base.
On summer nights, as the way tobogganists did, where they would pretend they were airplanes taking off,
and then when they got to the end, they would lift up and go over the fence around the runway,
and go out in the desert and turn around and pretend they were airplanes doing touch-and-goes.
Why do you think they were allowed to operate independently on kind of American military grounds?
Did, so the superiors were kind of unaware of that?
The base for them,
was like a foreign embassy.
And they've been here since the Ice Age.
Do you think it was the nuclear testing that, like, created some sort of wheeler tunnel or something that they traveled through?
Or like, why there? Why do you think they set up shop there?
Consider, I'm certain that the Greys got here first, and they were here before the last Ice Age.
And that the Tall Whites got here second,
and they were here by at least the middle of the last Ice Age.
And the Norwegians with 24 teeth got here towards the end of the last Ice Age.
The Tall Whites have the best technology.
The Greys have really good technology.
The Norwegians are just barely able to travel in space and make it here.
When you look at the bases and where the Tall Whites and the Greys are,
you have to look at the way they were in the Ice Age.
There's a place out in the deserts that I was in.
It's out in one of the most desolate sections of the western deserts that you can imagine.
There's an L-shaped valley with desert mountains on both sides.
And then there's a valley on the northern side.
But in the southern side, the valley is an L-shaped valley,
and there's a dry lake bed,
a small dry lake bed on the southern side,
and a huge amphitheater-type set of ground
that the Greys farmed during the Ice Age.
And in the mountain on the west,
they'd cut 13 tunnels in the mountain on the west,
and they used them as a granary.
And the first one on the north
was larger than the others,
and it was large enough for their deep spacecraft to come in and pick up grain.
And the 13th one overlooked the fields,
and at the top of the L-shaped valley
and at the bottom of the L-shaped valley,
the mountains form a constriction.
So if you were a Grey teenager
with an appropriate weapon,
and you were sitting there,
you could monitor both entrances,
and so if any Ice Age animals came in to eat the grain,
because they're plant eaters,
the Tall Whites and the Greys do not eat meat,
they're only plant eaters,
you could keep them out and protect,
keep them from eating your food.
And when you looked at the valley on the west,
you could see the ancient water lines
from how high the lake had been
during different stages of the Ice Age.
Now Central Nevada was never glaciated.
It was only,
it was just that in the Ice Age,
because the weather was different,
it rained lots and lots,
like it does in Kentucky.
And so those lake beds were not glacial lakes,
they weren't glacial carved.
They were poluvial lakes,
the Latin word for rain.
And therefore the bottom,
those lake beds were flat,
and the land leading into them
were perfect places to farm.
And what you were looking at was a granary,
a farm that the Greys used during the Ice Age.
So it sounds like there are all these unique reasons
as to why as an extraterrestrial presence
you'd set up shop in that area.
This is a really interesting point.
Something I kept coming back to
while preparing for this conversation
was this strange possibility of
what if Area 51's weirdness
didn't start because it's a military base?
What if the base was put there
because of a pre-existing weirdness in the region?
As Charles points out,
the broader pattern is hard to ignore.
Many of the most restricted military ranges
and test sites sit in the same kind of landscape.
Remote deserts, mountain valleys, and high plains.
And sometimes, Native American burial grounds.
Sure, there are practical reasons for this
when it comes to testing weapons and spy planes,
but often these places were tied up in UFO sightings,
cryptic creatures, electromagnetic anomalies,
before military bases were even placed on them.
Many were even seen to be portals to other dimensions.
Maybe it isn't just a coincidence.
Maybe the military wasn't just picking up empty land.
But claiming ground that was very unusual.
To put it bluntly,
maybe military bases often like to co-locate themselves
with very strange paranormal areas.
Skinwalker Ranch in northeastern Utah
is perhaps the most public example.
I've been there myself,
and you've no doubt heard the stories.
It's probably the most scientifically studied
paranormal hotspot in the world,
at least on the civil side.
Multiple UFO sightings,
glowing orbs, cattle mutilations,
and even reports of orange portals opening up in the air.
But it also has its former military connections.
There was a U.S. Army outpost in the region in the 19th century,
and today it sits not far from Dugway Proving Grounds.
In the 2000s, billionaire and government contractor Robert Bigelow
received Pentagon funding through the OSAP program
to research the ranch.
Why, you might ask?
Well, folklore from the Utah tribe had already marked the land as cursed,
prowled by shapeshifters.
That was long before the Pentagon made it a research site.
And if you zoom out, the geography is interesting too.
You can draw a rough triangle between Area 51,
Skinwalker Ranch, and Roswell.
Other paranormal hotspots with co-located military activity
exist all over the United States.
For example, Sedona, Arizona.
Local legends speak of tunnels and gateways hidden in the cliffs,
where star people pass through shimmering portals.
The Bradshaw Ranch there became famous for UFO sightings
investigated not long ago by Ross Coulthard.
Eventually, the site was taken over by the U.S. government,
a move that raised some eyebrows.
Why seize a random rural property in Arizona
unless there was something they felt needed securing?
To this day, locals still report black helicopters circling overhead
and interference with drones near the area.
It fits the pattern.
Land fenced off not just for practical reasons,
but because of whatever it is said to be in the land itself.
Land that seems full of electromagnetic anomalies.
And perhaps the same tunnels in land that are occupied by the tall whites.
And that brings us back to Nevada.
It's easy to forget that Area 51 isn't just one base.
It's part of a vast test range anchored by Nellis,
swallowing up thousands of square miles of desert.
Charles gets into this in just a moment,
but the history of how this whole area
ended up getting claimed by the government
doesn't quite add up.
Especially when it became a herd of desert sheep,
suddenly becoming an issue of national security.
And it begs the very important question,
how much of this pattern extends overseas?
Look at where the United States has planted some of its overseas bases.
Diego Garcia in the Indian Ocean.
Pine Gap in outback Australia.
Sprawling compounds in Iraq and Afghanistan.
Some of these sites already had
their own unusual reputations amongst locals.
Or maybe some other uses to our alien visitors from out of town.
Do you think it's a coincidence then that you get Area 51
and some of the most top secret advanced R&D
when it comes to the American military co-located on that area?
I subscribe to the Marine Corps theory.
If it happened once, it would be a coincidence.
If it happened twice, I'm sorry,
if it was happened once, it would be random.
If it happened twice, it would be a coincidence.
But the third time you see it's there,
somebody planned it.
Okay?
Yeah.
Now, remember, what else is out there?
The Desert Game Range National Park.
Okay?
Now, the Desert Game Range was set up
in the time of Franklin D. Roosevelt.
Okay?
It was what?
I talk about it in my book.
And it was like 1935 or 1937.
For some reason, FDR just got up all by himself.
And after talking with a single Army colonel,
Army Air Force colonel,
decided that the desert bighorn sheep
who live in the mountains like Sheep Peak,
for which it's named,
and the mountains to the east,
must be an endangered species.
You say, wait a moment, this is 1937.
I didn't realize we had endangered species
till 1970 or something.
This was 1937.
And by executive order said,
we got to make that a protected area
to protect the desert bighorn sheep.
They're white.
And if you're out there hiking
and you see something,
in the words of the park rangers,
that looks like a human,
looking at you from over the sagebrush,
which may be as tall as six feet,
don't look back,
especially if it looks like a woman with children,
because the bighorn sheep don't like that.
They'll attack you.
Just look away and walk away.
And in 1937,
in order to protect the sheep,
and we're talking before World War II,
Franklin Roosevelt and the Army Air Force decided,
that they would station a battalion
of anti-aircraft guns with live ammo
to protect it, okay?
So it wouldn't be subject to Japanese air attack.
And it was all that specific area.
And that specific area, right.
And that was the desert bighorn sheep.
Before there was an Area 51,
before there was a Nellis Gunnery Range,
before there was a Camp Mercury or anything,
there was,
the Desert Southwest Game Range.
So that's the first time there.
And you say that,
so the sheep are being protected
by an anti-aircraft cruise
that have live ammo,
and they're open to fire at any airplane
that goes across there in 1937.
And FDR just said,
well, I want the sheep to be safe.
And that's why it's called Sheep Peak.
And you say,
when you look at it,
Sheep Peak seems like a pretty easy place to climb.
Why is it that the first time,
it is a matter of record,
that it was climbed,
that anyone climbed it,
was 1970, okay?
You say, well,
we did Mount Everest before that, right?
Well, it sounds like, you know,
protecting sheep with, you know,
anti-aircraft technology,
the most advanced at the time.
Yeah.
It seems like if you'd fire a few live rounds,
wouldn't you kind of scare them a little bit, right?
So based on your rule,
if it's like, you know,
fool me once, okay,
fool me twice, fine,
fool me three times,
you know, that's sort of a,
you know, that's not a coincidence anymore.
What's the second time?
Is there a second time before Area 51,
which gets set up in the 50s,
that suspicious military or covert activity
occurs in the region
that might have to do with the ET presence?
Well, remember how good their technology is.
The technology of the one,
and the technology of the grace,
and I do not exaggerate.
I speak from direct experience.
When you say,
if they came here in the Ice Age,
and in order to,
and they're plant eaters,
and in order for,
to get a little help with harvesting grain
and doing manual labor and things like that,
there's nobody out in Nevada.
Where would they get that from?
Remember how good their technology is.
And I speak from direct experience.
If they wanted to use the scout craft,
which is,
oh, the tall white scout craft
or the gray scout craft,
which I,
both of which I've personally seen,
and in the time I've been talking,
if they wanted to say,
lift off from the backyard
and go to,
to the moon
and circumnavigate the moon
to check up on what's going on
in the far side of the moon
and return and land in the backyard right here,
they would have already done so.
That's how good their technology is.
One of the things I personally watched them do
from a distance,
because if you get too close,
the fields will burn you like a microwave,
but like from a distance of say,
like two and a half,
two and a half,
three miles was to lift,
was to go onto the scout craft
and sit down in the seats,
no seat belts or anything,
just chairs like this
and lift power up
and power up the,
not the outer coils,
but just the bottom and control coils
and lift off until they were floating
perhaps as far off the desert
or above the sagebrush as the height,
the camera is.
And then take a few seconds,
like 30 seconds
to power up completely the outer coils.
It takes a few seconds to do so.
When they do so,
before they do so,
the craft looks the way you're expecting.
If you saw a helicopter out there,
you'd see the actual metal of the helicopter.
But after they're powered up,
they just look real fuzzy white,
like a Tic Tac,
because they're surrounded with force fields.
You no longer see the actual metal,
you just see the force field
and the way it's fuzzing over light
and interacting with it.
Once they're powered up,
they're ready for high speed maneuvers.
Let's get into it.
If they choose to go straight down the line of sight,
they can go seven miles
at an average speed
of 8,000 to 12,000 miles an hour,
stop, power down, and set down.
And in the process,
they would have taken more than 15,000 Gs starting
and 15,000 Gs stopping,
just sitting there in the room like this.
And in case you're wondering how much that is,
10,000 Gs will liquefy steel.
The speed of light is like 86,000 miles per hour?
186,000 miles per hour.
186,000, okay.
Miles per second.
And they can do-
So if they're going 8,000 to 10,000 miles per hour,
there's still massive difference between that
and the speed of light.
They're not even in low gear.
Yeah, not even in low gear, wow.
If they do that and they choose to go sideways,
they'll go side, they'll just seem to blink out.
You'll be looking there
and they'll just seem to disappear before your eyes
because they will have accelerated
and moved to the side.
So fast, your eyes can't follow.
I speak from direct experience.
And if you're looking straight up Indian Springs Valley
and they choose to pop over to Dogbone Valley
and come down and then come in one of the northern passes
to see what you're doing,
it'll look like they just blinked out there
and magically reappeared over there
less than a second or two later
if they're in the hands of a skilled pilot.
A lot of people who still believe
in Einstein will mistakenly say
they went to another dimension.
Really, they haven't.
If you were in the way,
the craft would run into you.
There is no such thing as wormholes
or warping space and time.
What you're warping isn't space and time.
You're interacting with other force fields
that all matter has.
And, you know, the same way that
you might have an electric field
of different shapes
or a magnetic field of different shapes.
But time never slows down.
Time never runs in reverse.
Time is just time.
It always goes forward.
Have you ever flown in a craft?
Yes. Yeah.
A couple of times I did.
What was that like?
Well, I was in the cargo hold at the time
because there was, as I describe in my books,
the day after I thought I'd broken my kneecap
and then it healed up,
there was the next morning
when they came down to get me
and take me up to their base up at area 53
to see if I needed a surgery on my knee.
And was it the Tall Whites?
Yeah.
And when I got up there,
the American generals were there
and medical people were up there too.
And I didn't.
I just bruised it.
But the Tall Whites had to prove to the Americans
that they were telling them the correct
or wanted to prove that.
And so they came down and grabbed me
and put me in the hold of the cargo shop.
And I still remember the trip up there
and the trip back.
Where did they go?
Did you leave?
No, they just lifted off
and we just went gently up the valley,
perhaps 100 feet off the ground.
And I remember flying around range fours
and made the turn around range four
and then going up the valley to the,
they were going to the scout craft,
the back entrance to their scout craft hangar.
And the door was open and we went in there
and then there was a whole bunch of men there,
but there were also an American general
and some American medical people
and the six sergeants that was,
chief master sergeants that were the human guards
for the human generals
and the teacher in range four Harry.
And it was just like sitting here in a chair
only in the cargo hold.
And they didn't do it as,
they didn't totally power up
because they didn't have to.
And it was like sitting here in the chair
and having the whole room just be lifted up
and taken and come back.
And it was remarkably unremarkable.
The important part was that they thought
they had electronically hypnotized me,
but their equipment doesn't work
if you're sick or if you're angry
or if you're really tired.
And since I was, even though my knee was not broken,
I was still experiencing some pain.
You know, it was still tender.
It meant that the way my thoughts,
the blood flow in the brain was,
was somewhat different than the way it would normally be.
And so therefore,
when you use the electronic hypnotism on me,
that would normally have worked when I was ordinary,
if I was healthy and well rested, it didn't work.
I didn't quite do the job.
It's almost like anesthesia that doesn't work
during surgery or something.
Yeah.
So speaking of...
So I got to remember it.
Yeah.
Range four hearing knew that was the case,
but that was all he could do, yeah.
Why do you think they chose you for all of this?
Why do you think you were sort of picked
to be endowed with this knowledge?
One time I asked a different person
who was one of the top,
identified himself as one of the top three psychiatrists
at the CIA.
One of the time I asked him why they chose me.
Okay.
Because I said,
I thought there were lots of men that were better at
going out in the desert and surviving
and doing fixing trucks and so on than myself.
A lot of weather observers with more experience
and so on than me.
And he told me the following.
He said that,
and he had like nine PhDs hanging on the wall
for different facets of psychiatry.
And he was a very nice guy.
He was surprisingly young,
like in his thirties.
He said that when he studied psychiatry,
he was told that there was 105 different psychological defenses
that humans might use.
The most famous is whistling in the dark.
Okay.
He said that most humans only use one or two at the most.
That one of the people
that one of the projects that he and the others usually did
was trying to train colonels and generals
on how to have more psychological defenses.
They were hoping to get generals to use three,
or they always want them to use three.
They were hoping they could get them to use four or five.
This is of the 105.
And he said that he had told his,
the other guys that were with him,
psychiatrists that some of the,
there were a couple of,
there were some generals he was trying to train.
He thought he was going to get them to learn seven,
and he couldn't.
They were going to hang in there at three.
He said that the first time he met me,
he was shocked because in the first 15 minutes,
he saw me use the first 70 out of the 105.
And he was certain I could use the other 100,
the remainder of the 105.
And you can see it in my books.
He said the 41 men that went out before me,
who all came back compromised,
and some of them burned,
he said the problem they had,
in his opinion,
was that they recognized what they were up against,
or something of what they were up against,
before they understood how they were going to,
had decided how they were going to react.
Okay.
And he said that in,
and therefore what happened was,
in just the first encounter,
their psychological defenses got destroyed.
And he said that the reason they sent me,
he said if there ever was a person to send,
it would be you.
He said it's because they'll never lay a glove on you.
They'll never,
that, you know,
that no matter what happens,
you know,
you have a defense for it.
Okay.
And they had evaluated that prior to sending you out.
Yeah.
To commune with the Ethiopians.
They'll let,
they have a,
you know,
and you can see it in there,
in my,
there was a time,
when I thought that the extraterrestrials,
the extraterrestrial lady I was looking at,
that I was hallucinating.
And I was,
kind of surprised because,
I was kind of thinking that if I was gonna hallucinate,
I was alone out in the desert,
I was young and single,
that if I was gonna hallucinate,
that it would be more like a Las Vegas showgirl.
And she wasn't,
you know,
and I thought,
my God, how sick am I?
I'm not even,
you know,
see?
And she was laughing,
she,
cause she could tell that I was thinking,
because of her electronic equipment,
you see?
See,
and there was a time when I was,
there was a time when I thought,
that it,
that,
I must be short on vitamins,
when they would come into my,
barracks at Indian Springs,
and I would get up,
and I would see the children playing,
and I thought,
golly,
I knew I should have drank more milk,
it's for supper,
I must be short on vitamins and milk,
and so I would take more vitamins,
and they would still keep coming.
There was a time when I,
But you're also debriefing with generals,
who are admitting,
that this is a phenomena that they're aware of,
and that they're kind of,
working alongside these ETs,
is that right?
No,
I'm never debriefed.
You're never debriefed.
I'm never briefed,
I'm never debriefed.
But you're,
aren't you talking to the generals?
Not only,
that's not an accent,
my orders are,
I can never be briefed,
I can never be debriefed,
and the reason is very simple,
because the tall whites,
like the teacher,
can tell what a person is thinking,
even if they're not talking.
Well,
if you're debriefed,
and they're very touchy,
about their children,
if a briefing person were to say,
what kind of mother is the teacher?
You know,
how does she treat her little girl?
I mean,
she was lost in the sagebrush,
and you saved her life,
how did they let that happen?
See,
then,
they wouldn't have to ask me,
to tell them about it.
See,
they could tell it by just reading my thoughts.
The next thing they would demand,
is that somebody,
like that officer,
be delivered to them out in the desert,
and he wouldn't live another moment,
okay?
Yeah,
and she,
I wouldn't have to say anything,
or do anything,
or say,
because she could just tell,
oh yeah,
I read Charlie,
and I see that happened.
See,
so when I say that,
no one could ever ask me questions,
I could never be debriefed,
nothing I would do,
would ever be classified,
like no one could,
I mean,
they couldn't even inspect me,
if they wanted to talk to me,
they physically had to come out,
to the parking out of the chow hall,
at Indian Springs,
between noon and 1230,
and I would meet them there,
if I felt like meeting them,
or if I didn't,
then they would just,
and before they went out,
they would have to check in,
with the base commander at Nellis,
and when they came back,
they had to go directly,
from checking on base,
to the base commander,
and say,
yeah,
I looked healthy,
and so on,
and I could,
and they couldn't come out,
and inspect my barracks,
or see anything.
Have you,
you mentioned the,
CIA psychiatrist,
who said that you had,
all these psychological defenses,
and that sort of,
allowed you to,
enter into relations,
with the ETAs,
It allowed me,
and come back intact.
No,
it allowed me,
to protect my thoughts,
the person I am,
before admitting to myself,
they are real,
and I know what I'm gonna do.
Have you ever heard,
the name Kit Green?
Is that familiar,
to you at all?
It doesn't ring a bell,
but I probably heard him,
but see like,
see like,
like the first thing,
I agree,
the first agreement,
I made with him,
was after realizing,
they were real,
that I asked him,
that whenever they came,
around me,
that they talk,
between themselves,
if they were talking,
or with me in a way,
that I could hear,
to speak English,
because it,
frightened me,
if they were talking,
between themselves,
and it sometimes,
sounded like,
horse winnings,
or bird calls,
and they agreed,
and then the second one was,
that if I saw them,
out in the desert,
like if I came,
over a rise,
and there was one,
sitting on a rock,
I understood,
that it was easy,
for me to sneak up on him,
behind him,
and surprise him,
and I didn't wanna do that,
I would just stop,
where I was,
and stand where I was,
and sing a song,
and let them know,
I was there,
and then if they wanted,
to come closer,
I would just stand there,
and they could walk up,
towards me,
and stop,
whenever they wanted to,
I wouldn't pursue,
I wouldn't close the gap,
and if they got,
too close to me,
so that it,
I started feeling intimidated,
I would start backing away,
and they would stop,
and then when we had,
decided how far apart,
we were gonna be,
physically,
then we could communicate.
Your wife,
Marie-Therese,
mentioned that,
you actually,
were sent out,
initially.
Initially,
I was supposed to go,
from after doing my,
basic training at Lackland,
then I was put in,
PAT standing,
you know,
that was airmen,
airmen waiting,
security clearance,
okay,
and those airmen,
that were gonna get,
a security clearance,
and be sent to,
San Angel's,
Texas for,
security school 101,
we're supposed to wait there,
for like,
three weeks or so,
okay,
now,
the security clearance,
you're waiting for,
is whatever the government,
decides to give you,
but it's supposed to be,
the top secret clearance,
okay,
now the,
the security training,
the people in,
who are sent to,
San Angel's,
Texas,
are waiting,
to get their orders,
to San Angel's,
Texas,
however,
in my case,
they issue,
two sets of orders,
the real ones,
to San Angel's,
Texas,
and the cover orders,
to the weather training,
school at,
Schooner Air Force Base,
Illinois,
the idea is,
that the captain,
who is in charge,
of those guys,
who has a safe,
for classified material,
that's safe,
for the airmen,
who are,
you know,
classified material,
that's locked,
this is 1965,
times have all changed,
since then,
he's the one,
that will give out,
my orders,
the day sergeant,
can give out,
all the rest,
of the orders,
okay,
yeah,
because,
the day sergeant,
my clearance,
is going to be,
a higher clearance,
than theirs,
well,
the Friday,
that they came in,
the captain,
is off playing golf,
there's a military officer,
he's supposed,
to be in,
on duty,
he's off playing golf,
and left the sergeant,
in command,
the sergeant,
does not have the clearance,
to know about,
my orders,
so,
when the clearance,
comes,
the orders come in,
for everybody else,
and I'm,
we've all,
we were all,
in the same class,
together,
at boot camp,
I think,
a mistake,
has been made,
okay,
they get their orders,
I go in with them,
there's no orders,
I say,
well,
because,
my cover orders,
are in a different location,
than their orders,
but they're not locked up,
see,
they're just in the,
temporary out box,
well,
I asked the sergeant,
I got no orders,
aren't I going,
to weather school too,
so the sergeant goes,
and gets those orders,
and says,
oh yeah,
here's your orders,
and hands them to me,
to go to weather training school,
so I go out,
and I get on the bus,
you know,
I got my stuff packed,
now,
my drill sergeant,
had made a very special point,
he said,
keep two copies,
of your orders,
because you can't trust,
your officers,
right,
genius,
I keep two copies,
right,
okay,
so I get in the bus,
there's,
I'm not in the travel mask,
but I got orders,
so what,
so they throw me,
on the airplane,
and they send me,
to shoot at Air Force Base,
Illinois,
if you can't shoot them,
that place,
okay,
well,
I'm in the base,
and everybody else,
is getting paid,
and I'm at weather school,
and I'm the best student,
in the class,
and I'm getting paid,
and so I go,
and I ask,
the command,
my immediate commander,
can I go see,
I'm not getting paid,
he sends me over,
to the base payroll offices,
and they look at the,
their records,
and they're panicky,
you're on this base,
and they send me back,
to weather school,
I go back,
and two MP,
air policemen,
and a dog,
come in,
and grab me,
and march me over,
to the base commander's office,
I'm a little,
terrified,
and the base commander says,
Airman Hall,
if you have a copy,
of your orders,
showing you,
that you're supposed,
to be on this base,
then you're gonna be,
a happy man,
and the,
whoever gave you,
the orders,
is not gonna be,
very happy,
but,
if you don't have a,
copy of the orders,
the man,
who gave them to you,
is gonna be a happy man,
and you're not gonna be,
a soldier,
you're not gonna be,
a very happy soldier,
cause,
the generals tell me,
I'm a soldier,
you're too valuable,
a man,
to be wasted,
at this school,
I had two copies,
in my wallet,
I said,
thank you,
Sergeant Master,
Sergeant Peoples,
I graced his hand,
I said,
you need another one,
I can copy this,
right,
I was a happy man,
they said,
well,
we'll,
they will decide,
what to do,
right,
so,
they'd been looking for me,
at San Angeles,
Texas,
for six weeks,
the FBI,
had been looking for me,
the sergeant comes out,
and says,
you're going to Nellis,
okay,
wow,
yeah,
they said,
they gave me,
the usual wish,
wish list,
when you have your,
when you finish,
weather school,
name three places,
you'd like to go,
I said,
Germany,
England,
and,
March Air Force Base,
Los Angeles,
and they said,
no,
you're going to Nellis,
okay,
how soon,
after you're stationed,
at Nellis,
do you encounter,
this abandoned,
this time,
that,
I heard tell of the Tallwhites,
at Nellis,
was at,
my very first,
duty session,
at Nellis,
with,
another airman,
which I describe,
in my book,
okay,
he was the airman,
that had been on leave,
for several weeks,
because he claimed,
the,
Nellis weather station,
was haunted,
and it was the,
it's not the one,
you see there today,
it was the old one,
that was the,
northeast end,
of the base operations building,
the base operations building,
was a very nice building,
for its day,
as was the weather station,
I describe it in my book,
and it had,
something very important,
it was this military version,
of an airport terminal,
and,
it had something very important,
it had,
clean restrooms,
the next clean restroom,
was a mile away,
in a group of barracks,
they were still building,
to get to another,
clean restroom,
you had to go a mile,
and a half away,
okay,
he claimed,
that when he was working,
night graveyard,
and he was in his,
he had been in its military,
he was on his,
fourth year,
that he,
the previous winter,
that taught,
that he thought ghosts,
you and I would say,
a group of five,
tall white aliens,
had come in off the,
the runway,
off the,
the tarmac,
unlocking the pad,
the glass doors,
between the base operations,
the interior of the base operations,
building the tarmac,
because one of the force fields,
will make every piece of material,
repel every other piece of material,
and just pop every lock open,
and that,
when he came in,
there was one,
waiting outside,
standing guard,
one holding the door open,
or,
and,
one,
and then,
that's two men,
and then three women,
one holding open the door to the,
bath,
or,
to the bathroom,
another one inside,
holding,
helping them hold open the door to the bathroom,
while the third one was using the ladies' restroom,
and that they were rotating,
so that they'd come in to use the restroom,
he didn't,
he,
although he described them doing that,
he didn't appreciate what he was describing,
he thought they were ghosts,
he panicked immediately,
and started screaming,
locked himself in the doorway,
and,
in the,
and called the base air police,
only to discover that the Nellis base commander said no,
the air police cannot come beyond,
the road junction a mile away,
he's on his own,
okay,
now I know from firsthand experience,
that he was telling the truth,
because,
there came a day,
when I had,
work,
I was working graveyard,
actually a whole bunch of days,
on Sunday night,
when everything was empty,
when that would happen,
and the reason that they came was because,
they're just like us,
the bathroom that was a mile down,
which,
the mechanics down in that,
hangar,
airport hangar,
thought was,
was haunted,
was occasionally visited by tall white men,
who had to go to the bathroom,
and it was a mess,
never cleaned,
okay,
and if you're out with two people,
with two men and three women,
who wanted a clean bathroom,
and the one a mile and a half down,
was too far,
and wasn't suitable,
and you said,
where do we want to go to the bathroom,
you'd say,
I know just the place,
it's the one in the base ops,
and on Sunday night,
there's nobody around,
there's the weather observer,
and he's usually sleeping at night,
like he should,
okay,
he's not supposed to,
but usually they did,
actually that was a great place to sleep,
I did,
myself didn't,
I had too much fun reading books and stuff,
and so,
and the guy that I was,
he was my OJT instructor,
he also claimed that on a different night,
when he was in there,
that one of them came,
and peeked at him around the corner,
and said,
don't worry,
the women just want to use the restroom,
he screamed,
and called the police again,
and they wouldn't come,
and he had a nervous breakdown,
so you know,
and that happened to me,
I said,
yeah,
don't forget the candy bar machine,
you know,
you guys may be hungry,
right,
that's what psychological defenses do for you,
you see,
that's the difference,
and,
but that's the first one,
he told me the story,
but,
I didn't actually see the tall white son that night,
then a few nights later,
when,
he had been given an honorable discharge,
because the Pentagon insisted,
that he and I,
alone in the warehouse,
on Sunday night,
alone in the weather station together,
work,
at least one duty shift,
and then he would be given,
an honorable discharge of section eight,
which he was,
then when I was with my next duty shift,
my next OJT instructor,
and he was working a double shift,
I was working swing shift,
when I came left at midnight,
and I was trying to hurry to get to the base up,
to the base chow hall,
as I was walking back the mile or so,
to my barracks,
one of the new ones being built,
when I turned around,
following me was,
the tall white girl,
the 12 year old,
and I was about a quarter mile down,
from the base up,
from the weather station,
and backed by the white elephant,
was the teacher,
and two bridge for Harry,
and another tall white guard,
happily watching me from a distance,
and all she was doing,
was just following me,
intentionally showing herself,
at the time,
I,
when you talk about,
what good are such psychological defenses,
at the time,
I couldn't believe my eyes,
even though they matched,
what the guy had told me,
just a few days before,
I decided that because I was tired,
I must be sleepwalking,
and I'd said,
well gee,
I thought if you slept,
I didn't realize that,
you could actually walk,
and see things,
when you were sleepwalking,
and so I turned,
and I tried to continue walking,
I expected to hurry,
and get to my barracks,
before I had a brain stroke,
or something,
and collapsed,
and I thought,
and I turned around,
and after going a few steps,
and there she was,
she still followed me,
and I had been reading a book,
on the Titanic,
which I can talk about later,
and in the Titanic,
it described a group of angels,
who came in a craft,
land on one of the lifeboats,
and landed on the ledge,
of one of the icebergs,
and dropped wreaths,
for people in the water,
to use as life preservers,
which didn't work,
and how one of the angels,
was good at floating out,
over the water,
and dropping her hand,
and when I turned around,
and I was just watching her,
she smiled,
that girl,
she lifted up,
turned on,
she turned up the power,
on her suit,
lifted up a little bit further,
till the top of her feet,
were about as far off the ground,
as the top,
not as top,
almost the top of that chair,
flew over beside the sidewalk,
which was over the grass,
and saw,
and went over the grass,
a little bit,
and saw on the grass,
something that,
a piece of wrapper,
or perhaps a quarter,
or something,
that interested her,
and with her feet,
still in the air,
bent,
lowered her shoulders,
reached down on the graph,
and picked it up,
assuming the very same position,
that was described,
in the book on the Titanic,
that I had previously read,
like that night,
or two nights before,
described by the lady,
in the survivor of the lifeboat,
that was picked up,
by the Carpathia,
as described in the book,
that I was reading,
and it,
like she was the very same girl,
and considering that the 12 whites live,
600, 800 years,
10 times longer than we do,
she could have been,
okay,
and when I looked at it,
I was stunned,
and I still didn't make the,
the association,
between those people,
and extraterrestrials,
that's what psychological defenses do for you,
and I decided that I must just be,
sleepwalking,
or there must be something with me mentally,
and I went home,
and I went back to my barracks,
and life continued.
So,
let's get into the Hall photon theory,
because,
and just to set this up for the audience,
also in the 30s,
in 1935,
Einstein, Rosen, Podolsky,
come up with their sort of,
spooky action at a distance,
entanglement,
and it's known as Einstein's dilemma,
because Einstein,
had always kind of,
almost put a governor on reality,
the speed limit of reality,
is the,
you know,
speed of light,
and yet,
with photons,
observably,
you see this sort of entanglement effect,
where optical properties,
various optical properties,
seem to mirror one another,
at vast distances,
just instantaneously,
and so,
how is the Hall photon theory,
an update on that,
and how does that unlock,
faster than light travel,
in the form of a spacecraft?
Well,
to begin with,
I'd like to thank you,
for this nice interview,
and if I,
don't,
then,
be having us on your podcast,
Oh yeah.
I'd like to congratulate you,
on just out thinking Einstein,
okay?
When you say,
what's it feel like,
to be smarter than Albert Einstein?
I say,
well,
I know a guy,
it's not just me,
because what you say is correct,
and,
and the easiest way to see it,
is starting with the way Einstein did,
with the Mickelson-Morley experiment,
of 1897.
Yeah.
Okay?
In 1890,
which was a failure.
Yes.
In 1897,
everyone thought,
that a photon of light,
had only two force fields,
an electric field,
and a magnetic field,
that oscillated together,
okay?
And,
perpendicular to one another.
Mm-hmm.
And then they did the more,
Mickelson-Morley experiment,
and then they wanted to interpret it,
as though it were a,
experiment that you would do with,
little boats crossing a river,
and going up and down in the river,
when they didn't know anything about,
the fo,
they thought they knew everything there was,
to know about the photon,
that there was only two force fields,
so they could pretend,
that they knew,
everything about how a photon looks like,
a little boat going across the river.
Okay?
When the experiment failed,
then nobody wanted to say,
there has to be more structure,
to the photon,
than what we know about.
Mm-hmm.
Nobody wanted to do that,
okay?
They,
James Clerk Maxwell,
had done his equations,
and they didn't want to say,
there's more force fields,
that Maxwell's equations,
don't include,
but should.
Mm-hmm.
Okay?
The more,
and they oscillate too.
Mm-hmm.
They wanted to say,
we know everything there is,
to know about the photon.
Mm-hmm.
And then they wanted to say,
and we know everything about the river,
and the banks and stuff,
and the little boats that cross it.
So now they had reasoned themselves,
into a corner,
so why did the experiment fail?
And they monkeyed around like that,
until Einstein,
and they finally asked Einstein.
But I think of it as a failure,
to detect the ether,
the Michelson-Morley experiments.
Is that right?
To think,
a medium through which,
the photons would be carried.
That would make sense,
yeah,
not that there was no ether,
but then that left the question,
so why,
why isn't there at least some change,
why did the experiment totally fail?
Okay?
Along the way,
they ignored things about the experiment.
Mm-hmm.
The first one is that,
if you do the experiment,
with one photon at a time,
Mm-hmm.
in the interferometer,
you get the same results.
And that means that the photon,
has to be split in two,
for that to work.
Today we call that,
photon entanglement.
But back then,
they said,
well I don't know,
spooky at a distance,
right?
Okay.
And then if you do it with,
photons of just red light,
then you get the same results,
but the bright bands of light,
are still red light.
And so therefore,
the explanation that,
the photons would,
constructively interfere,
and destructively interfere,
can't be correct,
because,
if they constructively interfered,
they would have to change color.
Blue photons have twice the energy,
of red photons.
So that would mean,
you would be sending in blue light,
or sending in red light,
and looking at interference patterns,
of red light.
But that's not the case.
All that's happening,
in the interferometer,
is that the photons,
are being steered,
into bands of red photons.
That needs another force field,
to do the steering.
So what is,
if you have,
in traditional electromagnetism,
classical electrodynamics,
you have,
an electric field,
a magnetic field,
and a wave,
and they're all sort of running,
perpendicular to one another.
What other field types,
do you think exist,
in the whole photon theory?
A whole bunch.
Okay.
Like what?
And remember,
the force fields,
can be different,
force strengths.
The electric force,
magnetic force field,
is considered,
pound for pound,
to be like,
what,
a trillion times,
I might not have that number right,
100 million times,
more powerful,
pound for pound,
than the force of gravity.
Yeah,
it's 10 to the 40th.
But because the force of gravity,
is weaker,
pound for pound,
than the electromagnetic field,
the force of gravity,
can move further,
than light.
Okay?
So the force of gravity,
from our galaxy,
can affect the nearby galaxy,
the Andromeda galaxy,
at 2.7 million light years,
whereas the force of electricity,
from our galaxy,
cannot.
Right?
But,
Einstein wanted to ruin that,
analogy,
by saying that,
the force of gravity,
can move further,
than light.
Right?
But,
Einstein wanted to ruin that,
analogy,
by saying,
to protect his own reputation,
I guess,
I have no idea why,
trying to say that,
nothing could travel,
faster than light,
not even gravity.
But obviously,
if gravity can travel,
further than light,
it must be traveling,
faster than light.
If you look at the symmetry,
of the Andromeda galaxy,
and you say,
well,
it's 10,000,
100,000 light years,
200,000 light years,
across,
and that means that,
and it's so well organized,
gravity must be traveling,
trillions of times,
faster than light.
Otherwise,
if the stars were trying to do that,
and gravity was only traveling,
at the speed of light,
they'd all bump into each other.
Why do you,
so,
is gravity in your model,
also,
orders of magnitude,
weaker than electromagnetism?
Because,
if it's traveling,
that far,
it's pulling an effect,
a pulling effect,
between mass bodies.
If it's weaker,
then it could go further.
And see,
in the photon,
How does that hold,
if it's weaker,
it goes further?
Because,
it's like,
it's like the,
a milk truck delivering milk,
right?
If it's gonna go down a street,
and hit every house,
and it's gonna stop,
and interact along the way,
or at least stand ready to,
but if it's gonna,
just,
do one house here,
and a house 10 miles down,
the guy can go into high gear.
But I would think of,
like,
attenuation as being,
you know,
like a,
a way of being,
you know,
a certain amount of strength,
and then it attenuates.
The only way it can attenuate,
the only way,
a force field can attenuate,
is there,
say like grav,
I'll,
I'll say like,
gravity.
Mm-hmm.
Is for there to be,
an interaction cross section,
put up by another piece of,
matter,
or energy,
somewhere,
down the road.
Mm-hmm.
And then,
when it's traveling,
it's not trying,
to interact,
with the electric field.
Mm-hmm.
It's trying to interact,
with another gravity field,
and those are attractive,
to interactions.
And if it casts,
and,
and because it doesn't have to,
there is no interaction cross section,
between,
gravity,
and say,
an electric field,
that would be traveling things,
through,
then it could,
travel,
much,
much faster,
much further.
That's what the neutrino is.
Mm-hmm.
The neutrino,
we're told,
can travel through,
if everything between,
the center of the sun,
and here,
were solid gravity,
neutrino could travel through,
at all,
and not interact with anything.
Yep.
So therefore,
a neutrino can travel,
many,
many times faster,
than light.
Okay,
however you say,
well,
what about the neutrinos,
or a CERN reactor?
Mm-hmm.
Well,
if they're going to interact,
using electricity,
and magnetism,
and they have to slow,
to that speed,
Mm-hmm.
the electricity,
and magnetism,
to perform the interaction,
because,
time doesn't change.
Time is always flying,
at the same rate.
Mm-hmm.
They're all,
in the same timeframe.
Do you think we have,
neutrino detectors?
That's why,
neutrinos are so hard,
to detect.
Yeah.
But there are rumors,
that we have,
neutrino detectors,
like at the South Pole,
and,
you know,
sort of exotic.
Yeah,
the whole photon theory,
says that within,
that light is a bundle,
of force fields,
and,
there have to,
there have,
so there have to be,
a whole bunch of,
force fields,
in the photon.
Mm-hmm.
Okay?
And you must have to have,
variations of photons,
that have,
different collections,
of those different,
force fields.
Because,
you have photons,
and neutrinos,
which,
you see,
which are,
very similar.
Mm-hmm.
And,
those photons,
that means that,
even though photons,
that we're used to,
are limited by,
the speed of light,
because it,
because the electric field,
and the magnetic field,
have interaction,
cross sections,
that go,
that,
you know,
the permit,
permittivity,
of free space,
Mm-hmm.
and so on,
right?
Okay?
That it's,
has to touch base,
it has to vibrate,
all those piano wires,
if you will.
Mm-hmm.
When you,
if you have,
those other force fields,
be,
weak force fields,
like the neutrino,
is surrounded by,
weak interaction,
force fields.
They don't gotta vibrate,
the electromagnetic,
wires.
You see?
They only gotta vibrate,
their own wires.
They may not have to do it,
at all.
If you say,
well,
what are the,
permittivity,
of free space,
for those other,
force fields?
They're,
much less,
than those other,
force fields.
Mm-hmm.
Much less,
than the ones,
for electricity,
and magnetism.
What,
therefore,
when you say,
let me compute,
the speed of light,
for those force fields,
as I do in,
Beyond Relativity,
you come up,
with a speed,
a trillion times,
faster.
Charles,
using the Hall photon theory,
how would you,
build the UFO,
and how would you,
basically,
propel yourself,
faster than light?
Well,
I'll give you,
some general principles,
okay?
Based on,
what you saw,
in the deserts.
The,
the first thing is,
the UFO,
must be,
a smooth,
ellipsoid,
like an,
like,
like an egg,
or a Tic Tac.
Because,
the first,
the first principle,
of designing,
the different,
force fields,
and so on,
is there,
cannot,
be any,
turbulence.
What about,
a saucer?
Does that,
rule that out?
Okay,
and,
it depends on how the,
edges of the saucer are.
It can't,
and it can't have anything,
concave.
An example of,
something concave,
is if,
like on the camera,
you have the lens,
and it's,
shaped nice,
and then around it,
there's a ring,
that sticks out.
And in between,
where the lens,
meets the ring,
is concave.
If that,
were the shape,
of a,
spacecraft,
that you were trying,
to use,
to propel yourself,
through space,
you would be,
strictly,
limited,
to less,
than about,
80%,
the speed of light.
Because,
the force fields,
in that region,
would obey,
Einstein's,
theory of relativity,
because they're not,
streamlined in that,
area.
They would,
go turbulent.
And,
once they go,
turbulent,
the force fields,
will bump,
into each other.
The heating,
can go to infinity.
The amount of energy,
that's lost,
in that little zone,
could go to infinity.
But convex,
is fine.
So then?
Convex,
is fine.
Concave,
creates this turbulent,
kind of,
But if you took,
but if you took that,
if you took that lens,
and made it,
a complete,
ellipsoidal,
sphere of,
glass,
and you use that shape,
there's no,
sharp edges,
concave edges,
where there's just,
always egg-shaped.
Then,
when you surround it with,
a bubble,
of force fields,
they won't go,
con,
they won't go turbulent,
because they're streamlined,
for high-speed travel.
When you do that,
and you start accelerating,
towards the speed of light,
it'll,
it'll just continue accelerating,
as though,
the speed of light,
weren't there.
It'll just go,
right on through.
When you hear stories,
like,
Ryan Graves,
Navy pilot,
talk about,
a sphere inside a cube,
or other,
kind of,
exotic,
you know,
looking objects,
that do have pointy edges,
and,
you know,
don't always look like,
your traditional,
saucer,
or egg,
or tic-tac.
In the,
2003 timeframe,
a large group of,
Boeing contractors,
were operating near,
one of the launch facilities,
that served a,
very large,
hundred yard,
sided,
red,
square,
approach the base,
from the ocean,
and hover,
at low altitude,
over one of the launch facilities.
This object,
remained for,
about,
45 seconds or so,
before darting off,
over the mountains.
There was a similar event,
within 24 hours,
later in the evening.
This was a morning event,
I believe,
845,
in the morning.
Later in the evening,
post sunset,
there were,
reports of,
other subjects,
other sightings,
on base,
including some,
aggressive behaviors.
These objects,
were approaching,
some of the security guards,
at rapid speeds,
before darting off.
The force fields,
interact with light.
When,
when,
when you see,
and you can see it,
on the tic-tac video,
the Navy pilots.
When you look at,
when you look at the video,
the first question,
you have to ask yourself,
is,
when you're looking,
at the edges,
of the craft,
you have to ask yourself,
are you looking at,
just the force fields,
that are interacting,
with light,
that go away,
when the craft,
shuts down?
Or are you looking,
at the actual,
physical,
metal,
ceramic,
parts of the craft?
See?
And,
are you looking,
at a craft,
that was designed,
to exceed,
the speed,
of the craft,
or are you looking,
at the actual,
physical,
metal,
ceramic,
parts of the craft?
See?
Or are you looking,
at the actual,
speed of light?
Or are you looking,
at a craft,
that was just designed,
for a specialized,
general,
kind of purpose,
here on Earth?
Because,
remember,
the,
the scout craft,
that you see,
like the,
for the grays,
and the whites,
did not make,
the deep space crossing.
Only the deep space,
craft,
make the deep space,
crossing.
And,
the deep space,
craft,
make the deep space,
crossing.
What are the differences?
What's the main distinction?
The difference is,
The scout craft,
what,
we use RVs,
to get around.
Yeah.
See,
the deep space,
craft,
and I speak,
from direct observation,
they can all,
be individual,
like ships,
at sea,
or they can be,
general purpose.
Like,
but one,
for example,
looks like,
well,
you see,
how this house,
one that I personally saw,
was a little bit longer,
than this house,
a little bit wider,
about half,
again,
as high,
as this house,
and it was all,
totally smooth,
all around,
you know,
no protrusion,
or whatever.
It had the standard,
double hull,
and then,
it had another,
and the way,
this house has,
this room,
and then,
on the side,
it had another,
set of rooms.
So,
it had the double hull,
and then,
on the outside,
then,
it had a boundary area,
where you'd store stuff,
on both sides,
and then,
it had the living area,
where you had actual,
cabins,
the way you do,
on ships,
and then,
up at the front,
you had the,
cockpit,
and the control area,
up on the,
up on top,
and,
control lights,
up on top,
and then,
in the back,
you had the propulsion,
system,
and that was meant,
to put sand,
out to deep space,
and head out,
for stars,
through the light years,
away.
Okay,
I'm quite certain of that.
On the other hand,
see a saucer,
that,
you might have,
for your children,
to take out,
to the play area,
which I also saw.
It's not meant,
to go,
faster than light.
It's just meant,
to go,
like,
from,
Bishop,
California,
to Roswell,
New Mexico,
in a half hour.
You know,
and,
it's just meant,
to have a couple,
of teenagers,
take charge,
put in three,
younger children,
say,
eight or 10,
and go out,
and play,
and just go around,
places here on Earth.
So,
getting back,
to how you'd build,
the ideal.
See,
so,
when you build it,
if you build it,
for deep space,
so when,
and,
one that's,
has,
like,
that,
where you have,
a cube,
or something,
you might ask,
is that really,
one craft?
Or,
is it,
the center ball,
is the real craft,
and the outside,
is some,
something,
like a car,
pulling a trailer?
You know,
see,
you have to first ask,
who are they,
and what did they mean,
to use that craft for?
You see?
Because,
they,
because,
they don't just come here,
in a craft,
they build them,
while they're here.
Now,
Norwegians with 24 teeth,
can only repair their craft,
when they get here.
At least,
in 1965.
One of the things,
they wanted to be able to do,
was to work with,
the American government,
and build craft here.
And that's,
see,
so,
whenever you see a craft,
you,
whether it's a,
deep space craft,
or a scout craft,
or whatever,
you have to ask,
what's it meant for?
If you really expect,
to do high speed,
like 50,
like,
well,
like the scout craft,
that the tall whites had,
that were ellipsoidal.
One time I asked,
personally asked,
Range 4 Harry,
if that craft,
could exceed,
the speed of light.
He was a very nice guy,
we were like brothers.
He was very adamant,
he said,
it could,
but nobody,
I'm gonna use my words,
in their right mind,
would ever take it,
that fast.
Once you got up,
to about 1%
the speed of light,
you had to,
1% the speed of light.
You were covering distance,
so fast,
in his words,
that if anything went wrong,
your friends,
couldn't find you.
He,
and he didn't think,
it was made very well.
He wanted,
he pointed out,
that to repair it,
you had to sit down,
the craft down somewhere,
like in the desert,
and go outside,
and open it up,
to repair it.
But that the real,
deep spacecraft,
you could repair everything,
from the inside.
So the first thing,
that he thought,
that a deep spacecraft,
had to have,
was in addition,
to a double hull,
and fiber optic windings,
in between those two hulls,
to carry subatomic particles,
that would generate,
the force fields,
that you were working with.
That you had to have access,
from the inside of the craft,
to repair them.
You had to,
you had to be careful,
they didn't overheat.
If they overheated,
you had to have,
the design had to apply,
you had to be able,
to repair that,
from the inside.
If you got in trouble,
you had to have,
emergency beacons,
that used,
the force fields,
that travel,
faster than light,
to send for help.
Because the,
because,
those types of force fields,
that you're using,
in the,
design,
that you're using,
to send for help.
Because the,
because,
those types of force fields,
that you're using,
in the,
design,
like you could see it in,
you could see it in the,
in the,
TikTok video.
If you're gonna control,
radio,
infrared rays,
that are traveling,
at the speed of light,
you want,
if,
to use a force field,
that itself,
is traveling faster,
than the speed of light.
Otherwise,
you can't catch them,
and control them.
How,
the,
how does,
you mentioned,
that,
the engine,
or the propulsion,
is the only thing,
that the tall whites,
didn't,
kind of fully give,
the humans,
as far as the ability,
to sort of fly these UFOs.
Direct observation.
So,
yeah,
so what do you think,
as far as how,
the,
how does,
how do these engines work?
How are the,
what's the power source?
And then,
obviously,
it's not chemical combustion,
so what's going on,
in the engine?
I'm quite certain,
there's more,
subatomic particles,
more quarks,
than,
the six they know of.
There's at least,
two more sets.
But how,
how do you get,
how do you figure that out,
and when you,
Sorry,
you have these like large,
Hadron colliders,
it's like super expensive,
to build,
cost billions of dollars,
so,
how do you?
When you,
when you design,
when you sit down,
to design a craft,
there's five,
subatomic particles,
that are,
virtually always used,
because they're,
close to being stable,
and easy to work with.
And what you need,
is to have ceramic fiber,
you need,
in your engine,
you have to produce those.
So you have,
you don't have just one engine,
you have to have,
a way of producing,
all five of those.
And then,
what you have,
are ceramic fiber optic,
cables.
Ceramic fiber optics,
are 49.6%,
aluminum.
50.2% silicon dioxide,
that's the same as rocks.
And the remainder,
is the,
semiconductor,
germanium,
selenium,
and so on,
that you use to coat,
those fibers with,
to create fiber optics.
And then you,
wind those into coils.
And,
those are,
and,
whether you,
power up those coils,
or don't power up those coils,
that's how you,
control and propel your craft.
Okay?
And those five,
and,
and how you design those five,
depends on what you want to do with your craft.
There's two more,
types of,
subatomic particles,
in that family,
that,
are,
more unstable,
and are only occasionally used,
but not for craft,
that you would ever have children,
or a family on.
Cause all of the extraterrestrials,
travel as families.
They would only be,
you'd only find them on military craft.
And then there's two more,
and so far we've talked about a total of nine.
Okay?
That are so unstable,
that,
you would never use them,
when you were designing your craft.
You'd only use them,
if you were designing a military weapon.
And when you say,
that number five,
right?
And the number seven,
that seems to ring a bell,
doesn't it?
Because we're told,
that when Ike Eisenhower was president,
that there was a day,
that,
we're told publicly by ancient aliens,
and the old US press,
and so on,
that there was a day,
at somewhere,
the British guy said it was at Edwards,
other people said it was at Alamogordo.
But they say it was,
there was a day somewhere,
where he was taken,
where they took him out,
the day he was supposedly golfing,
at Palm Springs,
and went,
was taken to Edwards.
No cameras,
no press,
and sitting on the runway,
at Edwards,
were five spacecraft,
with extraterrestrials by them.
And the time,
that they were shown,
to Ike Eisenhower,
not one,
except for the guy,
whose name is Charlo,
looked at that and said,
that makes perfect sense,
that they would do five.
Because what they were showing him was,
the general features of how their airplane,
how their spacecraft were designed.
And you'd say,
why five?
It's because they were showing,
that there were five different,
subatomic particles,
and that when they designed them,
they first said,
I'm going to use this one,
for this purpose,
this one,
for the second one,
for another purpose,
and so on.
And so they were showing them,
that they had five different purposes,
for that,
in the design.
You see?
And,
okay,
but,
those who,
you know,
who,
who mean well,
think that they just arbitrarily showed five.
Another one is,
number three,
see,
the fiber optics coils,
melt suddenly,
at about,
somewhere between 1800 and 2200 Fahrenheit.
Not because they're made by aliens,
but because rocks melt between 1800 and 2200 degrees Fahrenheit.
And if they're 52,
50.2% silicon dioxide,
and 49.6% aluminum,
that's what they are,
is rocks.
And if they melt,
as they,
and if they,
if the fiber optics melt,
as they did during the Roswell,
the two craft,
that crashed at Roswell,
as described in my book,
The Valley of the Grace,
what you'll see,
you would think,
would be melted rocks.
I know,
UFO people try to pretend,
that there was one saucer,
and it was going fast,
and it bounced,
and it hit the ground,
and melted the rocks,
and then bounced up,
and went on.
And my answer is,
if you haven't,
you know,
when was the last time,
you saw anything bounce against the rocks,
in the Nevada,
you know,
New Mexico desert?
I never have.
Once they hit the rocks,
they break.
When,
the reason there were melted rocks there,
is because there were two saucers,
and the fiber optics were overheating,
and melting.
And when they melt,
they melt like melted glass,
or lava,
and they have a big chunk,
that looks like lava,
and a big chunk falls,
and then it hardens,
and hits the ground,
and looks like a melted rock.
So,
when you see those reports,
that the geologist came,
and his son said,
these are melted rocks,
and they left them behind,
then,
and they say,
we went out,
and picked up all the debris,
and we picked up this metal,
that resumes its shape.
I said,
those were cigarette wrappers.
Those were gum wrappers,
that did that.
What you passed over,
was the stuff you care about.
I found a piece of metal,
about a foot and a half,
to two feet wide,
and about two or three feet long.
It felt like you had nothing in your hands.
It wasn't any thicker,
than the foil out of a pack of cigarettes.
But the thing that got me,
is that you couldn't even bend it,
you couldn't embed it,
even though the sledgehammer would bounce off it.
So,
I knew that,
I had never seen anything like that before.
And as of now,
I don't know what it was.
So you're saying,
Jesse Marcel,
that was just like,
the sort of memory metal,
that was just the kind of exhaust.
That could have come off from a kid's toy,
okay?
Yeah,
because,
see what you have,
is what you,
after you've put in your melted,
after you've put in your coils,
then you have to protect them,
from the weather.
Now,
when you protect them from the weather,
you're going to have to cover them,
with a thin metal sheet.
Okay?
But you're not going to be able to support,
the metal sheet,
with an outside metal strap.
Okay?
You're not going to be able to protect the metal sheet,
with an inside metal strap.
Because you can't have turbulence,
in the force fields.
And you can,
the metal is electromagnetic,
will screw it up,
without stray electromagnetism,
and so on.
And when you're designing it,
you're going to start from square one,
and then three times a day,
you're going to come up and say,
I don't want any turbulence,
in this force field.
I don't want these coils to overheat.
You're going to leave,
if you're a gray designer,
and you're designing a coil,
craft for gray children,
then you're going to have,
as per the Roswell Museum,
you're going to have something that is missing,
from their display model.
On the underside,
you're going to have a little doorway,
that the operator of the craft can open,
anytime he wants,
and let molten fiber optics fall out.
Okay?
Because he's in desperate mode,
to save his fiber optics.
They have overheated.
And then he can close the door,
and take off again.
And if he does,
he may not be able to use all of his coils.
So if he's by himself,
he's in deep trouble.
As in the craft over the San,
plains of San Augustine in 1947,
he's by himself.
And he's got big trouble,
because,
but if he's got two craft beside him,
the fields from their craft,
and the fields from his craft,
will join together.
As I've personally seen,
Range 4 Harry,
do with the high-speed horse formation,
to form a single larger craft,
when the fields are present.
And stabilize his craft,
and now the three together,
can fly off to someplace safe.
Okay?
You need to use specific metamaterials,
for these,
you know,
very intense,
kind of,
you know,
environments.
And,
you know,
a lot of electricity.
And,
yeah,
do you need to use specific materials for the craft?
Before you can know about the materials,
you have to know about the subatomic particles.
Because the ceramic fiber optics,
are supposed to contain,
do what fiber optics do today.
What,
only they do it differently.
I've personally seen,
the fiber optics when,
as I describe in my book,
when I was in the sixth,
the summer after my sixth,
between my fifth and sixth grade.
When Ray Palmer,
the editor,
I believe that was his name,
editor of Flying Saucers Magazine,
in a store in London,
Wisconsin,
and his childhood friend,
who ran the store,
came back from Roswell,
with a stretch about a yard long.
And it was,
it was woven.
It wasn't a thin strip of metal.
It was like,
they took nylon fibers,
but it wasn't nylon,
it was ceramic,
and wound it.
And then when you flowed,
shined the flashlight through it,
the light would bend,
without being absorbed.
Now,
you,
but before you do it for the craft,
you first have to know about the particles,
because you have to know,
how to build the fiber optics,
before you can do anything else.
So Roswell,
you mentioned the Roswell Grays,
and you're talking about the Roswell Craft.
The lore is that it made its way to Wright-Patterson,
Wright-Airfield at the time.
And you're saying it eventually made its way to Area 51,
or to the Nevada test range?
I don't know where it made its way to,
but I don't care.
Because I've seen the real one,
and I know what it looks like.
According to just,
Where did you see it?
Did you see it in Nevada?
In Nevada.
I've seen a craft of that type many times.
On one,
as I describe in my book,
on the valleys of the Grays,
on one cold and snowy night in the fall,
back in the 60s,
when I damn near died in the fog.
And the scout craft,
with the young lady in it,
and some of her friends,
accompanied by the deep space craft,
and the teenage craft,
they had gone down to the bend in the road.
And she alone,
she was just learning to run the craft,
so they didn't let her take it up in the air.
And before the fog moved in,
when I was walking down there,
I was on the side of a hill,
I was alone.
And she had brought the craft in
on the paved,
on the gravel road.
She just had the control coils running.
And she had opened up the door on the side.
I was very reluctant to approach a craft,
because I knew from experience
that they all have those fields surrounding them.
And that if you get too close,
it's like walking into the back of a jet engine,
when the jet engine is running.
You gotta just stay and let them see you,
and let them come as close as they want,
or you'll get your ass burnt.
So I wasn't,
but she had powered down the other coils.
So from her point of view,
there was nothing keeping me
from just walking the final distance,
and stepping up into the craft,
and saying hi,
and meeting her and the others who were on the craft.
I didn't realize at the time,
that the teenager,
who was the backup pilot,
he was a young Grey.
They looked just like someone from Mongolia.
But the other three,
she and the other three,
were actually humans.
They were young Chinese people
that the Greys had rescued,
not abducted,
but they had been orphaned,
and the Greys had reputed.
And the whole point was,
that they were trying to return them
to human society.
But first you gotta find a human,
who everybody trusts,
including the children.
And the human has to be somebody
who trusts them in return.
And the human they had figured,
that they had chosen,
had this last name Hall,
and a first name Charlie.
Okay, they're Charles, right?
And you say,
well, why didn't they tell me?
And they say,
well, that's why we picked him,
because he'll figure it out
if we just give him time, right?
Why tell him early and scare him, right?
You know, that's why we picked him,
because he's perfect at convergent,
divergent reasoning,
and he'll figure it out.
And that's what they're doing,
waiting for me to come.
And what they had
was the very same craft
of the three that crashed at Roswell.
What they had was the very same craft.
And in the back of that craft,
do you think we know how to fly these crafts now?
Do you think humans know how to fly them?
I'll finish this sentence,
and then I'll answer it.
Yeah.
In the back of that craft was a restroom.
In the back of all those people
are real physical biological entities.
They all have to eat,
they all have to breathe air,
drink water,
and they all have to periodically
go to the restroom.
And therefore,
every craft in the back
has a bathroom.
You see?
And therefore,
when you say,
like the crash at Kingman,
the young lady that survived,
the sheriff there,
said that after she came out
and they were waiting for help to come,
what did she do?
In his own words,
he said she went back in the craft
and stayed in the back.
And the UFO people say
it must be a shrine
where she was praying.
Yeah.
And of course,
I think that's really laughable
because having seen the craft,
there's no shrine back there.
What there is is a bathroom.
And if the craft,
and there's also food storage.
And so if the craft has crashed
and she's got to wait a while,
like every other biological entity,
they're going to fall back
on the bathroom.
You see?
There's no reason to fall back
on the control panels
because the craft isn't running.
That's why they crashed.
See?
But the UFO people
all have this thing,
well, there was a time
they said in all this craft
there must be a shrine in the back,
you know, where they go and pray.
And you'd say,
no, no, no, no.
I've seen the craft.
They're going,
that's a bathroom, right?
And I have a whole class of stories
in that vein.
No, no.
And so when I say my advantage
is that I've been there
and seen that,
I say the wreckage
that was sitting in the,
run in the,
in the,
hangar at Roswell
that was recovered from Roswell,
when you say,
what was that like?
Well, that wreckage
had the bathroom
on the other side.
And so that meant
for the part that blew in
was blowing in
on the food storage.
You see?
And so when you went
on the wreckage of that,
I would guess
that you would find
on the other side
what remained
of the restaurant.
Which might not be very much.
I'm saying when,
okay, but,
now an answer to your,
what was your question
that you wanted me to answer?
I asked if humans,
can you mention that these,
there were these Chinese
occupants of the craft.
Do you think that humans
can fly these exotic,
you know, ET crafts?
It's like everything else
if they're trained.
Okay?
It's like if,
if they have an opportunity
to learn.
If they have a,
a training,
a trainer,
if they,
yeah,
it's not something
you can do naturally.
For the same reason
that a Cessna,
a Cessna airplane
is a,
they tell me
is a pretty simple airplane
to fly.
I've actually flown one
as co-pilot
for about 45 minutes,
but not by myself.
There was a trained pilot.
I was in the co-pilot seat
and the trained pilot
was in the pilot seat.
And it was a nice night
and all I was doing
was flying straight and level
and saying,
yeah,
I'm not moving anything.
Okay,
if you call that flying,
well.
Does,
does the training involve
the mind-matter connection?
There are rumors
that there are no control panels.
Do you sort of psychically
connect with the craft?
You don't do anything psychically.
Everything is electronics.
The electronics
either are adjusted
to tell what you're thinking.
And therefore react
because you're thinking
or to not work at all.
It isn't the person
that has to change
their way of thinking.
It's the person
who's adjusting the electronics
has to adjust it.
It's unique for each human.
So how many of these tall whites
were out there with you?
If you had to guess
or estimate.
It varied with
how many ships were in port.
See,
the,
the deep space ships
were,
would arrive
and would come
and go on schedule
the same way an airport is.
They liked to come
and go
near the
night of the full moon.
And on the night of the full moon,
the moon is,
the moon and the earth
and the sun all form a line.
So,
so behind the earth
and its orbit
is a,
you see,
is a uniform gravitational field
and it's going away
from the incoming craft.
So if anything goes wrong,
they can back off
and the earth won't run into them.
It'll go away.
This is much different
than the Norwegians with 24 teeth
who want to do it,
who want to come in
on the front side of the earth
because the Norwegians with 24 teeth
with less technology
must land at any price,
even if the earth runs into them.
So they're,
but the greys
and the,
but the tall whites,
the deep spacecraft
of the tall whites
want to come in
on the night of the full moon.
The greys
who have a base on the moon
come and go
at any time they want.
The,
the tall whites,
the craft are,
come on schedule
and they have different schedules.
Some are making
a two month schedule.
The longest schedule I saw
was craft
that take five years
and those schedules
and those craft
with a five year schedule
I was told
were coming directly
from their home planet.
Of course,
since the craft,
all the craft
travel many times faster
than the speed of light,
I'm not sure
where their home planet was.
But if there was no cra,
if there were no craft in port,
then the number of tall whites
at the base
wasn't particularly
large.
I'm not sure
what the number was,
but it would be rare
to see as many
as a hundred
out in the desert
if there were no,
if there were no ships
in deep spacecraft in port.
On the other hand,
the night that
Pamela was supposed
to pass her test
to head up
a technology transfer,
a tall white technology
transfer team,
by dressing up
and disguising themselves as,
and disguising herself
as a human woman
and the other,
the other tall white
by dressing up
and disguising himself
as a human man
specifically named Charlie Hall,
and she would specifically
pretend to be his wife
so they could go into
places like Livermore
and pretend to be humans
and talk to the,
the scientists,
I'm guessing.
Wait,
explain what you just said.
In a minute.
The,
the night she was going
to pass that.
Are you saying
that you're a tall white?
No,
I'm not a tall white.
I was born in Brooklyn,
Wisconsin.
My parents all came
from England.
Well then,
but they,
they mimicked you,
one of the tall whites
disguised themselves
as you and your wife
and then showed up
at Livermore Labs?
I'm guessing.
And how do you know,
well,
where did that come from?
I've never seen
any classified documents.
I'm guessing
only from my
personal experience
talking with the tall whites.
They've told you
that they
kind of used you
for inspiration
to infiltrate,
or not infiltrate,
maybe that's too aggressive
of a word,
but to enter
American scientific programs.
I'm just totally guessing.
But the night she was.
To show them how to
not be afraid
around humans
and to act easily
when in the presence
of humans.
Hmm.
That was his
Yeah.
whole M.O.
that he was supposed
to be there.
So they,
because they were
as terrified
of us
as we might
have been
terrified by them.
And it was.
Yeah.
That was
what the program was.
So what do you.
On that night.
Yeah.
On that night,
there were more
tall white scout craft
located up the valley
and on the eastern side
of Indian Springs Valley.
On what night?
The night that Pamela
was supposed to
play
past her final exam.
The crowd that formed
of tall whites
and a few human generals
and bigwigs
on the eastern side
of the valley.
There were more
than I could count.
I stopped counting
at 35.
But I guessed
there were at least
70 there.
There were so many
scout craft
and tall whites
that that whole side
of the valley
was white,
fluorescent white
people,
scout craft.
It looked like
a county fair
over there.
And all they were
going to do
is watch
her,
Pamela,
while the teacher
and Pamela
was there
over where
the ammunition bunker
was at
three and a half miles
was to
was to watch
her,
the teacher
and Pamela
walk down
the
paved
pathway
or
one lane road
from the
ammunition bunker
on the east side
down to about
a half way
where there was
a ridge
and then the teacher
would wait there
and then Pamela
with all
of her
technology
turned off
okay
on
totally
trusting
to
that I'm
a nice guy
to be around
okay
otherwise
totally helpless
against me
was supposed
to continue
walking down
the
down
pathway
until she
got to the
range boards
and then while
I was working
while I
was
had released
the balloon
and I was tracking
to just
walk
over
to me
disguised
as a human
she didn't
have to be disguised
as a human lady
just
wearing her
natural suit
to just
walk over
to me
the way you
and I
are
and then while I
was working
walk around
behind me
and turn
her back
to me
proving that
she trusted
me
just like
the scene
from the
man called
horse
where the
Indian chief
does that
to horse
turn around
and talk
to me
or everything
and then walk
around to the
others
with everybody
watching
and then walk
around and say
it's been so nice
to meet you
Charlie
and then
go on
then she
couldn't
leave
then
and her
husband
the guy
pretending to
be me
as her
husband
would then
have to do
it next
okay
and then she
wouldn't even get down
to the quarter
mile limit
when she panicked
and was afraid
that I was a
truly an ugly
monster
that she couldn't
trust and ran
off
but there came
a night
when she had
to do that
and that's
described in my
book
what do you
think the
tall whites
want with
humanity
do you think
they have goals
for us
or do you
think they're
for the same
reason that we
have a base
on Guam
the sun
and the solar
system
exists
in a
the middle
of a huge
void
in space
the next
closest
star
Alpha Centauri
or Proxima
Centauri
is almost
four light
years away
most
stars
or many
have another
star
within
two light
years
and it's
unusual
for many
stars to be
not more
than a
light year
apart
for the
sun
if you're
going to
cross that
big void
in space
as you're
conducting
interstellar
commerce
for your
own good
then it's
nice to have
a place
in the
middle
because that
void
is there for
you
to stop
and get
food
and water
go outside
your spacecraft
and repair
it
where you can
stop
and rest
and
but also
get minerals
or other things
that you might
need
so it's a pit stop
it's a pit stop
interesting
and of course
the reason that
there are many
of their spacecraft
doing that
is because
there's only
it is for the same
reason that there are many
other planes
that stop
at Guam
because
location
what do you make of
if you're there
it's a big help
if you have
some locals
who
grow some
food for you
they're plant eaters
the toloites
as the grays are
and
do the work
of harvesting
and hand you
the food
what do you make of
rumors
stories
that
like Eisenhower
you know
meeting possibly
this 1954
this treaty
you know
you say
five crafts showed up
there's another story
called
you know
Holman Air Force Base
where there's a landing
and
there's a possible
interaction between
you know
some generals
on the base
and
these
tall beings
but they seem to actually
have like
almost pharaonic
Egyptian
headdress
and
this was
this video
I think was promised
at one point
in the past
present and future
and
the video never came
but
I've spoken to
you know
some pretty interesting people
in the UFO whistleblower world
who
do
stand by that account
that that
that was like a real meeting
do you
do you think that that happened
and was it
was a tall
what was it
a tall white
that came out of the craft
at Holman Air Force Base
um
I'll maintain my policy
of never
commenting
on other people's stories
and
and the reason
the reason is because
uh
my books are based
totally on my own experience
yep
and
it's not based on anything I've read
or any
they're not based on any
any classified material
I was never part of any project
they're based on what
when you say
what was life
for me
yeah
and they're
and what
I'm trying to do in my books
one of the major things is that
one of the major things I'm trying to do in my books
is I'm
trying to tell my grandkids
how it was for me
and I'm trying to point out to them
that
when you're personally dealing with the extraterrestrials
you feel differently
than when you're personally dealing with your
guardian angels
your guardian angels are like brothers who love you
there's never any fear
this is the sensation that
your guardian angels are there with you
and they've
because each of us
I believe has two guardian angels at least
who are always with us
and have nothing else to do but keep track of
each one of us
and
and I
get so frustrated
when I see so many
humans
who mean well
trying to confuse
guardian angels
and what God
and love
and the guardian angels are
doing
with what
the biological entities who are
extraterrestrials are doing
and so
and that's what I'm trying to do in my book
I'm not trying to
I don't care what the government wants to classify
that's fine with me
if they want to classify the
recipe for Hershey candy bars
and say
you can have one Charlie but don't tell anybody
do you miss
do you miss the tall whites
do you feel an emotional affection
towards them
you said that
you and range for Harry were like brothers
do you ever think
hey maybe I could
contact
range for Harry
or go back and
speak to him
go back to the
to the range to Nellis
well
if I
let's say if I were out in the desert
let's say out by Dale
here in New Mexico
which is one of the tall white playgrounds
let's say if I ever were out there
and
and let's say I happen to see them
if I were to just say
well I just
wanted to
you know
monkey around and see you or
you know whatever
well
that
they might say well now you've seen us and so
go on about their business
see they're very goal oriented
even though they like us
and it's not that they're being rude
it's because remember
the teacher in 1965
who had been born
when George Washington was born
when she was playing with
when she was over at range two
that Sunday with her daughter
who she called the butterfly
and the little white girl
that she wanted to be friends with her little
with her daughter cause she
the little girls could be friends
she was standing there on the side
in a very now
they were playing on the skip bomb area
and the two boys were playing also
she was standing a little ways away from them
on the higher ground
slightly higher ground
she was very nostalgic remembering her childhood
where she played on the same piece of ground
with a little Native American girl
who was equivalent to her age
five years old at the time
but her memories of that
little Indian Native American girl
that was her very best friend at the time
in the time
because they lived ten times longer than we do
in the time that passed
while she went from
equivalently being say in the fourth grade
to the seventh grade
for us those are just a few years
in that equivalent time
the Native American
the Native American little girl
grew to adulthood
got married
had children
went through her entire life cycle
and died of old age
just in the time the teacher
had gone through
the equivalent lifestyle
from the fourth grade to the seventh grade
do you think they feel a fondness
for humans like
they do
but on the other hand
from their point of view
gee I'm eighty years old right now
you know I'll be dead
and what for them is
the blink of an eye
I don't know
even if I live to be a hundred
I'll
you know it's just two more
I only have two more years to live
so from their point of view
if I say we're out there
at my age
they would
you
they might
I mean they're friends
but
you have to remember that
socializing and being friends
for them with humans
is a little bit like us being friends
and socializing
with say
a dog in its old age
that we may not have seen
for five or ten years
there's a guy at NASA
who has a deep interest
in these sorts of things
experiencers
his name is Timothy Taylor
have you heard of him
by any chance
did you say Timothy Taylor?
um
Timothy Taylor?
yeah
he's a good friend of ours
oh so you know
you know Timothy Taylor
Tim Taylor
this is one of those characters
where well if you know
you know
but if you don't
there's probably a reason
why the mood shifted here folks
Tim Taylor was a NASA engineer
who became a biotech entrepreneur
and according to
Diana Pasulka's book
American Cosmic
where he appeared
under the pseudonym
Tyler D
has remained actively involved
in launch operations for NASA
up until today
Pasulka paints Taylor
as an enigmatic figure
who led her
and Stanford microbiologist
Gary Nolan
to a UFO crash site
in New Mexico
by many he's considered
a gatekeeper
well connected
with access to
crash retrieval secrets
as well as personally receiving
what he termed
downloads of information
from other worldly sources
he claimed these downloads
were facilitated by protocols
he engaged in
protocols that allowed him
to communicate
with non-human intelligences
in Pasulka's book
Taylor undergoes
a profound conversion
in the Vatican archives
blending technology
and the phenomenon
in what became
a personal revelation
and then he
he decided to convert
but also what happens
is he changes his idea
of what these things are
that he's feeling
he's getting signals from
because we were studying saints
who had these experiences
and he was thinking
that they're more in line
with what they were
you know
experiencing
too
and outside of her account
super experiencer
Chris Bledsoe's memoir
openly names Taylor
as a NASA insider
who befriended him
after his encounters
sometimes
Taylor would bring
other scientists
or officials
to witness
Bledsoe's experiences
I myself
was briefly in contact
with Taylor
and I'm not sure
what to make of him
and even though
I was shocked
that his name came up
in this conversation
I wasn't necessarily surprised
the deeper cut
on Tim Taylor
is that he himself
is some sort of time traveler
part of a secret program
adjusting timelines
this doesn't come from me
perhaps my favorite figure
aerospace engineer
and anti-gravity inventor
Thomas Townsend Brown
is connected
with Tim Taylor
this is where the story
gets weird
Thomas Townsend Brown
was obsessed
with anti-gravity
but gravity and time
have a tight relationship
in general relativity
this is just standard physics
so the subplot
of his great biography
by Paul Shatskin
the man who mastered gravity
is that Townsend Brown
was obsessed
with time travel
he would talk about it
constantly
with his friends
and family
apparently
Tim Taylor
told Ryan Bledsoe
Chris Bledsoe's son
that he was part
of a secret group
in Nassau
in the Bahamas
that dealt
with time travel
I would dismiss
this out of hand
entirely
but there are
some even more
interesting connections
between
Townsend Brown
and Tim Taylor
there's an Amazon review
that Townsend Brown's
daughter wrote
on Tim Taylor's biography
Launch Fever
in that biography
Tim Taylor talks
about his time
traveling back and forth
to the Bahamas
he spent a lot of time
in Nassau
Townsend Brown
also spent
a ton of time
in Nassau
in fact
his biographer
Paul Shatskin
even coined
a term
for a secret group
that used to meet there
it was called
the Nassau group
and it included
the elite of the elite
industrialists
like Eldridge Reeves
Johnson
and even
the inspiration
for James Bond
and Churchill's
super spy
William Stevenson
who helped form
the CIA
so maybe
Tim and Townsend
are part of a secret
time travel group
who knows
but it is interesting
that Taylor seems
to consistently
pop up
around very important
experiencers
in the United States
now back
to our conversation
how did you guys
originally
meet Tim Taylor
he's sort of
this very interesting
figure
and he's very
interested in
he came here
because
he found out
about Charles
and
that was when
his daughter
the one who had
the baby
was like
what was she
maybe in fifth grade
when they came
the first time
I'm
yeah
we
why do you think
he was
he became interested
in your story
my wife
can answer
all the questions
because
he
he realized
as far as
the
the real
article
was legitimate
and
as I say
it's really
concerned me
because I've
tried to
email
other people
because he
he brought
other people
to meet us
and
a visit
with us
they
one of the guys
cooked right here
in my kitchen
and
so I tried
to contact
those people
because I had
in emails
got a response
about what happened
to him
who did he bring
let me see
King
David King
wasn't that
his name
and
what it was
the
what was the
doctor
that was
I
I think
I still have
the emails
but
he brought
lots of people
here
and oh
brought them
to Las Vegas
Kit Greene
Dr. Kit Greene
maybe now?
I don't know
I've never been
to that house
I believe
he flew
he flew us
to
Atlanta
and
had us meet
the
oh
what was their
last name
now I can't remember
I know who you mean
honey
but I don't remember
that last name
either
we met
all his friends
they had a whole
house full of people
and entertained
us
interesting
what did
you get
big fans but because he introduced uh them to us what did you get this sense of like his job
at nasa do you do you know what he does he said that he uh was no longer in involved that he went
into business but for himself and he would oh that's the interesting story he'd been all over
to the various air force bases etc but he'd never been to creech before and so when he
came back from creech the first time he said he thought that charles underplayed the strangeness
that was going on there he said they were there for a ribbon cutting ceremony
and uh he was standing right next to a friend of his oh there were no lower ranking people
just all
officers and he said to the guy um do you mind if i just drive up the road you know a mile or two
i won't get out of the car and the guy said oh that would be a very bad idea and then
just that quickly he said i'm so glad you could make it for this you know like
i didn't say what i just said and uh yeah so he he was really even more um
impressed with uh charles uh account after he finally got the chance to visit creech for the
first time did he ever say where his interest in ets came from i don't remember that he said that
no there were many things we never talked about his work or things of that nature and
and um we also never talked about projects that he was associated with
or anything like that did he ever ask you about your hall photon theory um yeah i'm sure we talked
about it but he was interested actually in buying a house and moving out here he he seems to pop
in what when um experiencers have anomalous experiences we never had any trouble getting
in touch with him and as i say we the last contact we had was just when he said you know he was
looking forward to being a grand ph Rich's public commenter who was also a former senior during his time at the school.
father and that was it he just disappeared we never heard from him since i've heard that from
numerous people he did that i mean i had very intermittent correspondence with him but he
dropped off on me because chris bledsoe a bunch of other people so it's just that ours went on
for so many years yeah you said 15 years i think so yeah wow wow it's so strange that he would just
not contact you after 15 years though yeah i i mean we we shared a lot of really personal things
and you know of course he converted converted to catholicism yeah yeah recently in what in 20
like 15 16 ish something like that during his trip to the vatican yeah and he'd been he'd been
to rome several times after that so yeah do you think when he went to the vatican archives
he experienced anything around the et topic any confirmation of of that i have no idea but when
charles and i went to rome for the first time in 2000 what was that five six something around there
um i took the first three books as a presentation for pope benedict and uh a couple you know like
two months later when we were home
we actually got a thank you note from pope benedict really god yeah that's amazing i we put
uh i think we xeroxed it and put it in the in book four maybe wow yeah could we see that i'd
love to see the thank you note that'd be amazing oh it's in book four okay that's awesome do you
believe that timothy taylor has ever met an extraterrestrial he certainly didn't say anything
about meeting or has he shared any
personal sightings that he's ever had no but maybe the fact that he disappeared maybe
maybe he went off with them somewhere i don't know one night i was out in range three and a
group of new arrivals it was after the full moon a week or so and as usual a group of the guards
the the permanent the permanently assigned tall white guards at the base at the base at the base
up at the north end of india
springs valley brought down a they were using the the tourist model scout craft which had
seating for like two dozen and they brought it down that brought them down to the to the range
area so they could see me the first human that any of those tall whites had ever seen and while
i was there they they came in too close i expect them being new people to stop at least at a quarter
mile which is a lot of people and i think that's a lot of people and i think that's a lot of people
which was more common but they kept coming in because they were assured that i was a nice guy
until they were as close as you guys are well this was new the guard was in position
this was when i was still new and still not completely at ease being around them and since
the new people are armed too that meant that you know i was somewhat intimidated and what there
was an older lady or a middle-aged lady and i was kind of intimidated by the fact that i was
looking at them and and i was at my theodolite stand i was tracking the balloon and so i i said
well so i just turned to him and i said looked at him and i just said i'm feeling a little scared
and you know so i'm just going to put my stuff here and i'm going to go into base and you guys
can stay and look around and do whatever you want and have fun and then i backed away and i went
walking not running key point walking to my truck that was parked some distance away on the other
side of my
the generator shack and as i was walking this middle-aged lady said to the guard
she was kind of surprised she said we didn't do anything wrong did we i mean you know we didn't
and and the you know what's he like and the guard proceeded to tell the group
what they thought of i was like the guard said and i quote well he seems to talk more than most
humans
and he seems to eat a lot more than most humans and us but you know you don't worry if you and he
scares a lot more easily than most humans but see he's different he just goes in and talks and eats
and then he comes right back out the others once we find them would never come back and might not
eat again for a couple of days and they were all laughing so just wait here he'll be back out after
lunch just give him time to eat and talk to some of the other guys he'll be right back wow
you know well i think that's what they thought of me that encapsulates the fact that he's not
really not a good person at all right yeah well that encapsulates how i wasn't braver than the other
guys i scared easier but just let me eat and talk for a while i'll get over it well that encapsulates
i think you and how special you are because it shows in the um documentary that emile made as
well where like initially you are scared and you don't know what to do and i think most people
would have a reflexive allergic reaction and kind of run away and your reaction is just this kind of
i know 41 men that would agree with you yeah if if the not all of them would agree yeah i think maybe
still alive right oh oh interesting so for 41 men who were had nervous breakdowns set out before me
and came back came back compromised compromised meaning mentally unstable some of them but some
of them just wouldn't go out there again just well the one the guy before me had deserted but
the one i remember the one i always felt sorry it's the one i described in my book he was the
one that was out at range four one night and when they first sent him out there and the tall whites
came in the and i'll use my words not his the tall whites came in the high-speed horse formation and
they came from the northwest mountains that when you're in indian springs amount to the north and
northwest it came down and they were coming across the dry lake bed at range four and they were very
close to where
and he was he was at the weather station at range four and he couldn't believe they were real because
they were floating and when he so he went out there and surprised him and he got too close to
him because they still had their suits powered up and they were still in the tall white for in the
high in the floating in the high-speed horse formation and he got too close to him and the suits
on the swingers would hit the top of the horses they would have two supports and two supports up
there and when i was on the swingers and after the two low chores i saw him and i kept talking to him
it's so funny because you'd see him they seem when they were turned up high enough they would sparkle
you could see the alpha particles and the beta particles was coming out and the other particles
you could actually see the decay chains coming off the suits and the suit and his shoulder almost
touched one of the shoes and i saw his x-rays and pictures wow at the when i was at the nellis base
wounds from the hero victims of the hiroshima blast and it looked like his whole show the
meat the found everything had been cooked off wow okay yeah it had been cooked off and you know the
bone was exploited and he just barely made it back to base alive did you ever did you ever experience
any radiation damage due to interactions with them or no not that i'm aware of and part of the reason
was because part of the reason was because you could see the the fluorescent if they had their
suits turned up high enough you could see the radioactive decay particles and of course i
recognized them immediately as radioactive decay particles because in those days in the early 19th
that was in 1965 we'll see in the early 1950s you could still get radium paint and put it on your
watch or your toys
and if you had a magnifying glass and you went into a very dark room and waited like 45 or 50
minutes for your eyes to perfectly adjust to the darkness and used to radiation magnifying glass
you could actually see the subatomic particles come off
the radium paint the alpha particles of beta particles of gamma rays and see so when i saw
those coming off there's the suits of the tall whites out in the desert i knew perfectly well
where i was surprised by how big the part of those tracks were and how far they carried when it came
off from radium paint the tracks would be coming off just a short distance like that when you saw
them out in the desert they'd be coming off distances like like that there so those suits
had a tremendous power charles yeah this has been an absolute honor i appreciate your time man